here with reaction former Secretary of
State and Fox News contributor Mike
Pompeo secretary Pompeo great to have
you the language of the Biden
Administration appears to have changed
Biden was asked are you close to a deal
on the hostages he said quote I believe
so with his fingers crossed John Kirby
his spokesperson said we're closer than
ever this is different than what we
heard previously which is look we're not
going to negotiate on hostages from the
podium why the change in
language KLA that's great to be with you
um I suspect that they've been working
to try and figure out how to bring these
people home I I pray that that's so I
pray that they all get back to their
families uh but the cost of doing that
it appears the B Administration is
Raising that is they're raising the risk
that Israel will be told to stand down
to stop the destruction of Hamas which
is necessary for the protection not only
the Israeli people but for America as
well uh I don't know what they're
contemplating in terms of an arrangement
I I want want these hostages home I I've
met with these families I it is horrific
but every one of these losses of life is
a responsibility of the Iranian regime
and Hamas the fact that there are
innocent uh gazin being killed that's
the responsibility of Hamas and it is
the responsibility of Iran and Hamas to
return these prisoners and to ask Israel
to do a deal which will give Hamas the
chance to rearm regroup and reload
presents enormous risk not only to the
soldiers of the IDF but to the hostages
themselves you know and I just think of
how 10-month-old
bius I I mean he spent a tenth of his
life think about that a tenth of his
life in the hands of Hamas Terrace it's
a tragedy but a lot of people may not
realize during our Administration during
the Trump Administration we had great
success in getting hostages release
Ambassador Robert O'Brien you secretary
Pompeo all key in that what made the
Trump Administration so successful that
adversary said yes it is time to release
an
American Kaya we were serious people
people and this is an Administration
that has been deeply unserious when it
comes to pushing back against the
Islamic Republic of Iran and its hostage
taking you'll remember it's not that
long ago that we paid $6 billion dollar
in Ransom to get back five Americans and
within just a handful of weeks there's
now more Americans than that held by the
Iranian regime when you are unserious
the bad guys perceive that they can move
about the cabin freely they can take
Americans they can fire over four dozen
uh attacks on American Soldier Sailors a
Marines in the Middle East they can do
these things with impunity because the
administration hasn't demonstrated a
credible deterrent threat that's the
fundamental difference when you are
serious uh Nations will return those
that they have wrongly held uh they
won't attack your folks and when you
demonstrate real resolve when you are
prepared to actually deliver on the
Promises you make you you are prepared
to defend the red lines that you have
drawn you can convince the bad guys to
step back and sadly the bid
Administration whether it was in
Afghanistan where there were 13
Americans killed or now with these
attacks in the Middle East on our
soldier Sailors a Marines uh we've lost
that very deterrence that we had for
four years kayy and you bring that up
the the Iranian attack 61 61 attacks on
American Service members in Syria and
Iraq and there's this line in the
Washington Post and you know how this
works you know every Department in the
Administration has a press team and
there are things that leak and
oftentimes people leak to the Press when
they're unhappy with something when they
disagree with the actions of the
administration here you go and
Washington Post a senior defense
official said the Pentagon has provided
additional options to the president
beyond the actions that have been taken
to date that's against Iranian proxies
this person affirmed too that within the
Department of Defense there is growing
doubt about the present approach is this
members of the Pentagon unhappy with
President Biden and the weakness he's
he's taking because they they're giving
him other options he has other
options uh kayy I'm sure that's what it
is you're right this this happens in
every Administration it happened in ours
to when when they don't get the answer
they look for some bureaucrat leaks
something in this case I'm confident
that's true I'm confident that President
Biden was presented a full range of
options almost all of which would have
been more more responsive more
aggressive more protective of these
American soldiers than the ones that
they've chosen to date and so I think
the Pentagon is that signaling hey we
got to do more if we're going to deter
the Iranian regime we we have to at
least acknowledge that they were the on
responsible for what happened the
barbaric attacks of October 7th when in
fact the B Administration has just
refused to acknowledge that we have to
do the fundamental blocking and
attacking to protect Israelis and
Americans and frankly the broader Middle
East against these barbaric attacks by
the Iranian regime itself you know one
of those Iranian proxy groups is the
houthis you know them well because
here's what you did to the houthis who
by the way they've taken out a $30
million American Reaper drone they're
now seizing ships that are linked to
Israel that's what they're doing up to
no good here's what you did on January
15th of 2021 you designated them a
terrorist group January 15th Biden
February 4th delists them as a terrorist
group why would he possibly do
that it's unexplainable Kaylee uh
they've now committed Terror attacks uh
in abundance over the last two and a
half years further demonstrating that
what I did in January of 2020 excuse me
2021 was correct um they are terrorists
they're terrorist that much like Kamas
much by Hezbollah much by like the
militias that are operating inside of
Iraq they are funded trained directed by
the Iranian regime I can't for the life
of me imagine why the bid Administration
chose at the very beginning of its time
to delist them other than they wanted to
go the B Administration wanteded to go
on bended knee to the Iranians to try to
get back into the silly nuclear deal
that President Obama had gotten us into
in the first place well that bended knee
resulted in dead Americans and now
American hostages such a tragedy peace
through strength out the window
secretary Pompeo thank you very much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else